[Music]
in this video we shall travel back to
ancient japan when two titans
the muta prime and a member of godzilla
species called dagon
had a fierce battle that inadvertently
led to the events of godzilla 2014
but before we explore this let's start
with a little bit of introduction into
both of them
let's start with dagon also dubbed as
5146 adam
he was a member of godzilla species
being a part of the same species dagon
had many of the traits of godzilla
himself
this includes jagged dorsal plates dark
coarse skin
yellow eyes gills wide feet a robot's
head and short forearms
dagon was a bit shorter and maybe less
heavier than godzilla from 2014
so let us assume that it was around 340
feet tall
and 500 feet long weighing 80 000 tons
there is a belief that he was in fact
godzilla's father
regarding how he was as an individual
dagon did not exhibit much of a
personality but it appears
that he had a tolerance for humans
allowing them to get close to him the
same as the g-man
he was extremely durable and had a lot
of stamina as well as the iconic atomic
breath
so let's go into the other corner the
muto prime
also dubbed as titanos jinshin mushi or
simply jinshin mushi
it was a gigantic parasitic dai kaiju
that appears in a 2019 graphic novel
godzilla aftershock the ancient japanese
gave her the name
jinshinmushi or the earthquake beetle
due to her ability to create earthquakes
and her beatle-like appearance monarch
names her demuto prime because
she was larger and more powerful than
the regular mutos
the muto prime was significantly larger
than the regular female muto
and had a hard and outer shell covered
with razor sharp back spires
large cloth full limbs covered in orange
scales as well as several smaller pairs
of volumes protruding from her abdomen
prime's jaws are more defined along with
larger and sharper mandibles
her exoskeleton is metallic black in
color and she possesses two
red visor-like eyes and protruding from
the offices of her skull
are faux arrow-shaped ovipositors with
an orange bioluminescent hue
although her height is never stated
muter prime was much larger than dagon
but shorter than godzilla himself so
maybe around 350 feet tall
she was also 50 heavier than godzilla
which would put her
around 135 000 tons
she was also classified as a destroyer
titan she had various powers like the
sonic roar
which were her primary ranged attack she
had the same emp pulses which can reduce
the strength of the atomic breath
as well as heavily armored folims that
were deadly in a fight against any titan
so now that we have the background of
these two bees let us see how their
encounter happened
and what was the result so it was 1100
bce
and the scene was ancient japan there
were ancient human colonies that broke
off from the prehistoric civilization
that was destroyed after the war with
the titans
dagon which had been tailing the smaller
mutos and might have killed quite a few
of them
resurfaced by the shores of some unknown
japanese islands
standing tall as an alpha titan he was a
sight to behold to the people living
there
distraught by the death of her offspring
and unknown to dagon the muto prime was
stalking him waiting for a chance to
pounce
out of revenge and make mince meat out
of him but it knew that this fight would
mean
life or death for either one of them but
the bell has rung
and the duel cannot be cancelled so
muter prime came out from the ground
and slammed against dagon shocked by
this dagon stood up and ran towards the
murder prime
but it being larger and heavier the
meter prime managed to overpower him
with her earthquake arms
dagon then managed to charge up his
dorsal plates and shoot an atomic breath
at prime
but due to her powerful emp it was a
weak flame that came out
and even at that it managed to get her
off of him
now both of them stood up again and rode
at each other and at this moment daegon
was again
charging up his atomic breath but the
prime was faster at it
delivering her ultimate attack the sonic
roll that broke a few of the plates on
daegon's bank
now this brought daegun back to the
ground and as he tried to stand up
prime stomped on him with her huge arms
and took the opportunity to inject
him with her overpositors laying a
couple of spores inside his body
this left dagon unconscious for a while
and with the task done
the muta prime retreated back into her
hole and went underground
never to be seen again for more than
3000 years until 2014.
so yeah that was it the battle between
dagon and muto prime
although he managed to survive the
battle he was doomed as the murder spore
slowly killed him from inside
feeding off of his radioactive blood he
later succumbed to this
and he laid dying far away in the
philippine islands
anyway that's about it for this video do
leave a comment down below and tell us
what you think
it's been a blast so hit that like
subscribe and bell button
before you check out more of our videos
take care fam